Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Kids in the U.S. haven't always had summers
off.
In rural areas, they went to school in summer
and winter to help during planting and harvesting
while urban kids went year round.
In the mid 1800’s schools shifted to a standardized
fall-spring schedule allowing for family vacations
and to give relief from buildings with no
air conditioning and doctors at the time supported
this - saying that summers off would also
help protect kids' brains from overuse.
Meanwhile, kids are getting smarter.
The "Flynn Effect," shows that IQ scores improve
markedly with each generation.
Professor James Flynn found that if students
a hundred years ago took today's IQ test,
they'd average 70, while if students today
took the test 100 years ago, they'd average
130.
Explanations include better healthcare, nutrition
and more schooling…
And the fact that people before the scientific
age were often adverse to classifying things
they couldn’t use - and didn’t routinely
engage in hypothetical or abstract thought.
Neuropsychologist A.R.
Luria tested this on a socially isolated farmer
about a hundred years ago and it went something
like this.
What do a chicken and a dog have in common?
Nothin’.
A chicken has two legs, a dogs have four.
Chicken have wings - dogs don’t!
Okay you’ve explained how they're different
but how are they alike?
They’re not.
Is there one word though that you could use
for both of them?
Nope.
What about 'animal'?
Would the word ‘animal’ fit?
Yes.
Online courses are commonplace now but Sir
Isaac Pitman actually established the first
distance learning course in the 1840’s.
Pitman taught shorthand by mailing postcards
to students and correcting the answers that
they mailed back.
In the 1920s, educational radio programs were
considered textbooks in the air.
And today there are over 2,200 courses available
online around the world.
For free.
While South Korea is using robot teachers
to help children with learning disabilities,
a kindergarten in Switzerland is bringing
education back to its roots.
Literally.
They have a school outside in the forest where
kids attend rain or snow learning to build
fires and shelters alongside their ABCs.
And as always - thanks for watching.
It's School of YouTube week and you can make
a difference to the millions of children worldwide
who won't be going back to school this year.
Whether due to lack of teachers, school materials
or worse so click on the donate button - if
you can - to help spread ideas and knowledge
to everyone.